le patron de mcdonald's s'est fait
montrer la porte en raison d'une liaison
avec un membre du personnel
cette liaison était consensuel
apparemment mais le conseil
d'administration a estimé que steve
easterbrook avait enfreint le règlement
de l'entreprise il fait preuve d'un
mauvais jugement
steve easterbrook 52 ans avait pris la
tête de mcdonald's en 2015
au cours de son règne il à accélérer
l'automatisation et la rénovation des
restaurants simplifier les menus est
investi dans l'application mobile et la
livraison à domicile
steve easterbrook aura droit à une
indemnité de départ de six cent soixante
quinze mille dollars pourra conserver
ses options également d'une valeur de
plus de 35 millions mcdonald's a aussi
annoncé le départ de son responsable des
ressources humaines
le nouveau pdg et christine ski qui
présidait la division américaine de mc
donald's sébastien parent est avocat
doctorant à la faculté de droit de
l'université de montréal chargé de cours
à polytechnique également bonsoir en soi
que dit le code d'éthique exactement de
mcdonald's évidemment n'a pas la copie
clair on n'a pas accès aux copies du
code d'éthique mais sincèrement à ce
qu'on comprend des différents articles
ont été écrits sur le sujet sexuelle
interdisait aux membres la direction
donc des gens qui ont des postes très
haut placées d'avoir des relations
amoureuses avec des gens sous leur
subordination directe ou indirecte donc
un direct dès qu'on a un post très haut
placées tout ce qui se trouve en dessous
dans dans la hiérarchie dans
l'organigramme se trouverait temps
subordination indiqué qu on comprend que
le pdg ne pouvait pas avoir de relation
amoureuse du tout avec qui que ce soit
dans cette entreprise qui n'agrée
pourquoi pour qu est ce qui est
problématique dans ça la plupart des
raisons qui sont évoqués par les
employeurs c'est que ça use à éviter les
conflits d'intérêts le favoritisme ont
un emploi et delà de la haute direction
lorsque six sacres open où son cas pas
une promotion dans l'entreprise est ce
que c'est par du favoritisme ce parce
que vraiment les compétences dans toutes
les questions là l'empereur a vu les
éviter autant que possible et l'autre
raison c'est les informations censées
banc
pdg d'entreprises un directeur général
avec ça des informations stratégiques
les orientations de l'entreprise et même
les conditions de travail qui vont être
négocié pour les salariés que ce soit
éventuellement ou actuellement et donc
on veut pas que ces informations ne
soient communiqués à la maison lorsque
sont à la rue personnel donc cesser
toutes les principales raisons qui sont
évoqués sans considérer toutes les
conséquences néfastes que ça paiera sur
le climat de travail entre les employés
disent ah ben ça c'est ma vie privée ça
vous regarde pas le travail je dois te
sentir et avec qui je veux mais quand la
rupture
évidemment le conflit s'étend souvent
sur les lieux du travail aux employés
oublier un peu la ligne qui s'était
tracée pour justifier cette relation là
il ya toutes sortes de conséquences à
peu un milieu très néfaste est ce qu'il
ya un enjeu réputationnel également pour
l'entreprise c'est possible ou si le de
préserver une certaine image de empêcher
que les cards sortent avec des employés
on veut garder une certaine une certaine
image de ce qui ressemble au sud est ce
que pour un enjeu moral dans ce aussi
évidemment l'on se pose c'est un employé
à moux femme qui a larger la personne
alves aussi ça peut jouer ça peut même
devenir une agression sexuelle au sens
du code criminel d'un gerald mcdonald's
qui sortirait avec une employée ou un
employé de 16 ou 17 ans le code criminel
interdit aux personnes en autorité
d'avoir des relations sexuelles avec les
démineurs de 16 17 ans parce que c'est
des personnes en autorité donc un
employeur un professeur tous ces gens là
ne peuvent par deux rassure même si
c'est consensuel avec un mineur de 16 ou
17 ans et la danse cossue de toute façon
on ne connaît pas si je me trompe pas là
un atelier d'information on connaît pas
l'identité l'âge de la personne n'a le
personnel qui était en relation avec le
pdg mais parce que ça peut arriver chez
nous au québec au canada que ce genre
que ce genre de choses là n'y a pas
énormément de précédents sur la question
mais le fait que l'employeur interdisent
des relations amoureuses dans son
entreprise
ça met en jeu des droits fondamentaux
des salariés dans ce que si ce droit à
la vie privée ainsi l'emploi commencent
à s'ingérer dans avec qui on peut sortir
avec qui on ne peut pas sortir
ça touche directement la sphère de
l'autonomie de l'individu donc sa vie
privée et ça peut même être vue comme la
discrimination fondée sur l'état civil
on congédie quelqu'un ou ont refusé de
l'embaucher à cause d'une relation
intime qu'il avec des jeunes en
entreprise donc ça s'appelle la
discrimination fondée sur les tests
civile de la presse c'est à l'employeur
de justifier sa politique ou le congé du
monstre un congédiement qui a été
invoqué ce qui ressort des
jurisprudences on peut faire des
parallèles avec les politiques de
népotisme c'est à dire qu'on interdise
embauche des gens qui ont des liens
familiaux pour éviter les conflits
d'intérêts les lignes directrices en
matière y en a qui prennent la cour
suprême ont adopté des codes application
des tribunaux inférieurs une
interdiction large de tous les employés
ne peuvent pas avoir de relations dans
l'entreprise avec un collègue ou avec un
patron ce serait trop large ce serait
pas justifiable selon les décisions donc
interdire à deux employés de même niveau
de bonnes relations
habituellement ce serait difficilement
justifiable par contre des illustrations
on dit lorsque ces des directeurs
généraux des illuministe ou encore d'une
mauvaise qualité elle en avait déjà
considéré que les liens familiaux 1
pouvait donner lieu en apparence de
conflit d'intérêts donc c'était correct
d'interdire les embauches de ces gens là
donc on peut tirer des parallèles de ce
cd postes de haut niveau dans
l'entreprise
ça pourrait être justifiée mais une
interdiction large avoir ce type de
relation parce que l'on prend un repos
gérer ça à ce moment là ça serait prêt à
considérer comme déraisonnable
est ce qu'on a déjà vu ça ici que des
congédiements lié au fait qu'un
directeur aux dirigeants d une relation
avec une relation amoureuse avec un wind
employés j'ai trouvé une très vieille
illustration à qui s'apparente un peu à
notre que c'est dans la pharma c'était
un gérant
adjoint d'un établissement donc dans une
succursale walmart qui avait noué des
liens d'amitié avec une employée
d'amitié ça a été plus loin que l'amitié
il ya eu des captations par caméra vidéo
de gestes de nature sexuelle qui sont
survenus sur les lieux du travail
pendant les heures de travail
c'est grave c'est considéré comme du vol
de temps chez terra et le congédiement
été annulée par le tribunal du travail
parce que et c'est très beau quel est le
juge dit on ne peut pas à l'emprunt ne
peut pas empêcher deux personnes de
tomber amoureux même si un code
d'éthique dans cette entreprise là ce
que savoir le code d'éthique semblable à
mcdonald's qui interdisait les relations
amoureuses entre les employés de gestion
les gestionnaires et les salariés dans
ce que si on annule le congédiement pour
le remplacer par une suspension de six
mois donc on a même si l'exemple le plus
prêt que j'ai pu être trouvée on disait
que la politique en soi n'est pas
suffisante pour justifier le
congédiement faut vraiment voir falloir
analyser l'ensemble des circonstances je
pense que le pdg de mcdonald's avec les
primes de départ et les options qu'ils
ne va pas contester sans aucun doute son
congédiement
sébastien parent merci pour ma chanteuse